police in Raleigh North Carolina have
arrested a juvenile suspect in a Brazen
series of killings there five people
were shot to death yesterday including
an off-duty police officer along a
public public path in a residential area
police swarmed the neighborhood
searching for the shooter East Preston
is outside a hospital in Raleigh where
at least one of the victims is in
critical is in critical condition at
this hour Elise good morning to you
good morning to you Gail police have not
released any more information about the
person hospitalized here or those four
other victims killed they say the
suspected shooter is an underage white
male his alleged crimes in the words of
the state's Governor terrorized this
usually quiet area for hours
Raleigh Police raced through these
residential streets around Sunset
Thursday responding to reports of an
active shooter
cell phone video appears to show Law
Enforcement searching the area for the
suspect five people were shot and killed
including an off-duty police officer we
have it all sit down we have an officer
down but I've never seen so many cops
like I'm shaking and terrified to go
home and sleep tonight then some four
hours after the first reports of gunfire
police confirmed the juvenile had been
taken into custody the suspect had been
contained at a residence there's no
active ongoing threat in the community
at this time among the two injured a
Raleigh Police K-9 Officer who was
released from the hospital Thursday
night and it's not just in Raleigh
Across the Nation seven officers have
been wounded and five killed by gunfires
so far this week this year 55 law
enforcement officers have been killed
compared to 62 in all of last year among
those killed this week Connecticut
officers Dustin De Monte and Alex hamzi
they were apparently ambushed Wednesday
after a false 9-1-1 call a third officer
Alec urato was injured but was released
from the hospital to Applause Thursday
morning
[Applause]
back in Raleigh a call for change we
must stop this mindless violence in
America
address gun
can we expect to learn more about the
victims killed the wounded and the
suspected shooter at a news conference
this morning Tony
Governor Roy Cooper called it the
nightmare of every Community Elise thank
you very much